[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission politique hebdomadaire
au sommaire les annonces des manuels
macron sur la sécurité en déplacement à
nice le chef de l'état toujours pas
candidat a annoncé un plan à 15
milliards d'euros doublement des
effectifs de police d'ici 2030
harcèlement de rue plus sévèrement punis
ou encore plus de moyens contre les
cyberattaques valérie pécresse la
candidate des républicains est
immédiatement monté au créneau en
attaquant le bilan du chef de l'état
pourquoi avoir choisi ce calendrier
emmanuel macron essaierait-il de chasser
sur le terrain de la droite que propose
valérie pécresse pour contrer ces
annonces c'est le débat de la semaine
alexis poulin et jacques de guillebon
vous livrent ensuite leur avis sur un
actu du monde d'après mais d'abord forte
mobilisation dans le secteur de
l'éducation aujourd'hui enseignants
directeurs d'établissements et même
parents d'élèves ont battu le pavé dans
toute la france un jeudi noir pour
dénoncer un protocole coville trop
compliqué et pénalisant l'enseignement
alors comment réagit le gouvernement
commet cette grève pourrait impacter la
campagne mais commençons par une
première question messieurs face à des
mesures aussi contraignantes
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer bientôt
la mise en place d'un pass vaccinale à
l'école
bonjour alexis jean jacques oui
évidemment et ce gouvernement il faut
s'attendre à tout et notamment en
matière d'administration de surveillance
et de tête il y aune mans si je peux
dire donc oui évidemment on pourra voir
parce vaccinale demain si tenté que
monsieur véran pense que ça s'applique à
tout le monde et qu'il fallait
surveiller encore plus la population
française qui n'est pas encore assez oui
alors le pass vaccinale à l'école c'est
encore loin parce qu'on a seulement 2%
un des enfants de 5 à 11 ans qui ont
reçu une dose de vaccin la majorité des
parents qui sont contraints ou au moins
ambitieux avec la vaccination des
enfants contre le coc vide donc le pass
vaccinale n'est pas à l'ordre du jour à
l'école même si le sénat a amendé et
voter cette mesure pour le reste de la
société non ce qu'on voit c'est surtout
des protocoles sanitaires qui sont
incompréhensibles que les parents
n'arrivent pas à suivre que les
enseignants non plus et qui sont
ravageurs pour les élèves en terme de
que de connaissances de continuité
pédagogique enfin là on est rentré dans
quelque chose de l'ordre de la folie je
pense que les parents d'élèves se rendre
compte quand il a fallu tester trois
fois les enfants pour les remettre à
l'école parce qu'ils avaient
éventuellement un cas contacts dans une
classe alors qu'il fallait pas fermer
enfin quel est le prix découverte de
jean michel blanquer en terme
psychologique pour les enfants et en
termes d'organisation pour les familles
c'est ça la question je pense que c'est
aussi pour ça que la grève ait autant
suivie aujourd'hui oui c'est sûr ça fait
maintenant presque deux ans que le
l'enseignement les professeurs les
directeurs d'établissements et même les
parents d'élèves se plie aux règles qui
sont édictées qui changeaient en
permanence et blanc caire où il dit
l'école est ouverte en fait elle est
ouverte pour qui on a des dizaines de
témoignages centaine même de professeurs
qui se retrouve avec deux ou trois
élèves en classe la moitié qui doit
partir au milieu du court une autre qui
arrive c'est incompréhensible
invraisemblable autant pour les parents
que pour les enseignantes même pour les
territoires de médicaments qui doivent
édicter de nouvelles règles tous les
jours donc on comprend que cette grève
arrive enfin qu'elle soit aussi suivi
parce que c'est quand même en tout cas
dans le primaire puisque c'est là où on
sait dans le premier degré c'est 75% des
enseignants aujourd'hui ils sont qui
sont en grève pour le reste il faudra
voir au cours de la journée comment ça
va se passer
aimer c'est évident qu'on ne peut pas
arriver à autre chose quand on a
cette manière de procéder de ce
gouvernement c'est vous avait deux
sortes de bons délais vous avez le bon
élève qui est brillant naturellement et
qui sait ce qu'il faut faire et vous
avez l'autre qui a compris quelque chose
qui plaisait à la maîtresse c'est un
marché une fois et donc il va le faire
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours et faire le
même chose là donc ce gouvernement c'est
cette bonne élève lakehal i sorte de
rigueur et une sorte de peur panique de
déplaire et donc il ya trouvé en fait
cette manière d'administrer les gens
équivalent appliquée jusqu'à la fin oui
mais là je crois qu'il ya une vraie
cassure enfin avec au micron les règles
ont changé c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit
mise de la santé il ya une passe d'armes
d'ailleurs entre 10 et 20 ans et jean
michel blanquer à la sortie du conseil
des ministres apparemment les deux
ministres ne s'apprécient guère parce
qu'évidemment on ne comprend plus
comment ça peut fonctionner à 400 mille
cas par jour ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elles sont mille malades mais quatre
cent mille cas c'est énorme 45 mille
élèves enfin bref en termes de détester
tracé isolé ça ne peut plus fonctionner
donc il faut trouver un autre mode de
d'opération le problème c'est que ça
fait deux ans que le virus est là que
les enseignants n'ont pas été dotée en
masques ffp2 il le disait pourtant on a
déjà eu le le cirque que le sketch des
masques il ya un an les purificateurs
d'air ne sont pas là on a les ministres
qu'il suffit d'ouvrir les fenêtres mais
quand il fait 2 degré zéro degré ouvrir
les fenêtres pour donner cours c'est pas
très confortable voire dangereux donc on
continue à faire que me si on pouvait
bricoler ou qu'on a des protocoles qui
sont devenus de l'ordre de la folie pour
c'est magique on à jean-michel bancaire
qui dit on ne fait pas grève contre le
virus évidemment que non mais les gens
qui sont dans la rue aujourd'hui n'ont
pas fait grève contre le virus ils ont
fait grève contre ce ministre est contre
ce gouvernement qui commence à
sérieusement cassé les pieds des
français avec des mesures
incompréhensible et inapplicable et
parfaitement hypocrite le gouvernement
le même les mêmes le cf est de fait
depuis un mois qu'on sait que ce virus
notamment le variant au micron va
circuler le gouvernement a décidé de le
laisser circuler parce qu'il sait qu'il
peut pas l'arrêter bien sûr et en même
temps comme il veut dégager sa
responsabilité encore une fois qu'il
veut appliquer ces mêmes méthodes ils
créent ces protocoles qui sont
insupportables pour tout le monde en
nous faisant croire que ça va arrêter le
virus que l'école reste ouverte en même
temps et qu'il se passera rien mais
qu'on voit donc le niveau de virus qui
circule à la fois à l'école et la faune
en population française on sait très
bien qu'il a lâché la sphère pas comme
tous les gouvernements d'ailleurs du
monde parce qu'il est impossible pour
l'instant d'arrêter ce virus ce variant
dont heureusement
qui a l'air moins grave que les
précédents mais le but final non dit
c'est quand même que tout le monde la
trappe tout le monde et l'immunité et
qui n'a pas d'autre méthode pour le
faire aujourd'hui oui c'est ce que dit
alors mille guez qui s'y connaît en
virus mais lui parle du 2 au micro ondes
qui fait rentrer le coc vite dans une
grippe saisonnière c'est à peu près le
l'angle de tous les médecins du monde on
a même le ms qui commence à douter des
rappels successifs qui pourrait être
dangereux pour l'immunité c'est l'
agence du médicament heureux même si le
dis que ça va s'éteindre naturellement
exactement où on a là on al'impression
une réaction à contre-courant à
contretemps de la france avec le pass
vaccinale alors qu'on à 77% de la
population vaccinée donc tout va très
bien de ce côté-là et des mesures qui
sont devenus trop contraignant pour les
français et c'est le point de rupture je
crois qu'on arrive là à quelque chose où
le gouvernement ne comprends plus ce qui
se passe les français non plus et à part
faire peur il ya plus rien qui
fonctionne oui et on va voir si le coup
de poker qui avait tenté emmanuel macron
là avec son j'emmerde les non vaccinés
et notamment c'est protocole là si ça va
durer parce qu'on voit qu'il est là
qu'on commence un petit peu à descendre
dans les sondages fins et a confirmé
peut-être que c'est dû à ça et on voit
cette grève qui va être gigantesque et
priorités pas rêver depuis longtemps qui
peut être peut faire reculer
gouvernement et peut-être va finir par
changer voir que son son clivages
artificiels trop vacciner non vaccinés
ne va plus fonctionner dans le reste de
la campagne alors ça dépend certains
comme christian estrosi soutien du
président et venait de macron veut aller
plus loin avec des taxes avec interdire
l'accès à l'assurance chômage des non
vaccinés donc on voit que les bons
élèves comme vous dites veulent
continuer à maltraiter parmi la
population française pour le reste je
crois que c'est l'ensemble de la
population qui a ras-le-bol total de
cette pandémie qui est en train de
devenir maintenant une épidémie de
grippe saisonnière et espérons le
croisons les doigts mais là il faut
passer à autre chose d'autant plus qu'on
a une campagne présidentielle qui est en
cours et on ne peut pas parler que d'eux
qu'ovide non-stop nous on fait ça depuis
déjà un an c'est fatigant là je crois
qu'il faut vraiment passer à autre chose
sachant que au micro les chiffres sont
plutôt rassurants compte tenu du peu
d'hospitalisation du fait de se marier
place au débat de la semaine à nice
emmanuel macron a présenté ces annonces
pour la sécurité des mesures s'étalant
jusqu'à 2030 même s'il n'est pour le
moment toujours pas candidat attaqué sur
son terrain la droite et notamment la
candidate heller valérie pécresse n'a
pas tardé à répondre en pointant le
bilan du président de la république
justement messieurs en 2017 c'est manuel
macua fait de nombreuses promesses sur
ce sujet
ces nouvelles annonces sont elles un
aveu d'échec selon vous
c'est plus qu'un aveu d'échec en fait
c'est pourrait mener le maquereau une
façon de cacher d'éviter son bilan
puisqu'il est clairement candidat même
s'il ne le dit pas même s'il n'est pas
officiellement déclaré toutes ces
annonces et ça depuis le déplacement à
marseille en septembre sont uniquement à
but de se projeter dans l'avenir de
d'enjamber finalement l'élection
présidentielle comme si elle n'avait pas
lieu pour ne pas avoir à défendre son
bilan qui est indéfendable notamment en
matière de sécurité et la valérie
pécresse a effectivement un boulevard
donc c'est une manoeuvre une
manipulation de plus d' emmanuel macron
valérie pécresse a un boulevard mais il
faut voir que les idées qu'elle reprend
viennent de plus à droite qu'elle même
et donc il ya une sorte de transfert qui
passe par valérie pécresse jusqu'à mais
ne la grande idée qui viennent de marine
le pen et eric zemmour à l'origine sur
la sécurité mais c'est évident que
emmanuel macron est tenu en échec sur la
sécurité parce que c'était pas son sujet
je me souviens de deux caciques de la
république en marche qui disait en 2016
2017 quand on a fait campagne on pensait
qu'il suffisait de régler des questions
sociales de faire de la théorie de du
ruissellement n'enrichissent mans et que
tout se passerait bien que la sécurité
et l'immigration notamment n'étaient pas
des sujets ils s'en sont aperçus à peu
près au milieu du quinquennat gérald
darmanin qui vient de la droite dite
plutôt dur a été nommé ministre de
l'intérieur mais c'est pas suffisant
quelques quelque argent qu'il dise qui
va mettre sur la table pour l'instant on
n'en voit pas les fruits on voit pas
comment s'est organisée ils disent on a
rajouté 10000 forces de l'ordre ont vos
points sans les français ne le voit pas
et ils sont en train de tenir le
discours qui est tenu depuis 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans agent dire faut être plus de
policiers plus de gendarmes sur le
terrain - d'administratifs on entend ça
depuis qu'on est né quasiment et on n'a
toujours pas vu mais la revanche ça
coûte pas cher de dire qu'on va mettre
15 milliards dans les 8 années qui
viennent si tant est qu'on soit encore
président comme on le prévoit oui c'est
ça alors c'est systématiquement la
réponse de ce gouvernement ou de la
majorité ça a été des chiffres des
chiffres stratosphériques pour l'hôpital
on parle de milliards pour la police 15
milliards sur la table on va embaucher
mais la réalité du terrain elle est
toute autre quand vous regardez le
malaise dans la police que demandent les
policiers des moyens évidemment que les
commissariats soit rénové c'est aussi un
métier qui souffre avec on lave un déçu
si d'un taux de suicide impressionnant
c'était 59 car en 2019 une hausse de 60%
par rapport aux années précédentes les
faits de violences contre les policiers
aussi qui ont doublé carrément en disant
disant même pas en cinq ans on était à
2 cents 2916 fait violence contre les
forces de l'ordre recensés à paris et
tout ça n'a fait qu'augmenter ces huit
cas de violence par jour contre les
policiers enfin la réalité de ce métier
c'est la violence c'est aussi l'absence
de reconnaissance et la difficulté de le
faire et donc qu'est ce qu'on propose le
gouvernement comme d'habitude 15
milliards mais ça veut rien dire 15
milliards tout comme avoir commandé des
blindés avoir commandé des gaz
lacrymogènes la réalité de ce métier
c'est le manque de formation le manque
de bras et aussi une violence de la
société qui n'a fait qu'augmenter depuis
des années oui comme c'est le grand
philosophe pierre boutang les chiffres
c'est ce que l'on sait quand on ne sait
rien et c'est le cas je pensais
médailles macro mais s'il veut qu'on lui
oppose les chiffres on peut le faire
aussi dans ses promesses de campagne
avait qu à l'ouverture de 15000 places
de prison les a jamais vus face à ses
taux de façon quarante ans qu'on nous
promet des nouvelles places de prison on
les a pas vus il devait par ailleurs
créé une académie de police on l'a pas
vu non plus ouvrir à trouver la première
instance dans chaque département on l'a
pas vu non plus
et etc etc c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'ils se réveillent
maintenant
à trois mois de l'élection pour dire oui
à un problème de sécurité dans ce pays
il se déplace à nice donc sur les terres
symbolique de eric ciotti qui est le
monsieur police on peut dire de valérie
pécresse pour essayer de montrer que lui
aussi peut passer le karcher que lui
aussi
un des gros bras et c'est uniquement des
promesses qui n'ont donc ne n'engage que
lui et là dessus on voit que c'est fait
c'est un sujet quand même qui est un des
plus clivants que c'est des choses que
les français eux ressentent le plus
après le pouvoir d'achat c'est peut-être
le ce qui arrive dans leurs priorités on
voit bien que les réactions de tous les
candidats contre lui ont été violentes
là-dessus marine le pen qui parle de
kant de président de l'ensauvagement
eric zemmour qui dit que les racailles
les gangs et mafia se moque de ces
annonces et même jean luc mélenchon qui
dit qui va perpétuer une politique
inefficace avec ses propositions
jusqu'en 2030 bien sûr mais tout le
monde a en tête cette image alors
emmanuel macron emmerde les non vaccinés
mais rappelez vous lors de son
déplacement présidentiel où il a enlacé
un délinquant qui a fait un doigt
d'honneur à la caméra avec le président
de la république c'était là un message
dépérissement et non mais c'est quand
même assez impressionnant de voir la
façon dont ce président a toujours
traité la sécurité comme un non sujet
finalement comme quelque chose qui ne
préoccupait pas le quotidien des
français parce qu'il a voulu mettre
l'économie d'abord parce qu'il a voulu
aussi ne pas en faire un sujet parce que
trop clients on le voit tous dès qu'il
est question d'agir sur le régalien
c'est gérald darmanin qui doit monter au
créneau alors il ya marlène schiappa qui
fait un peu de décoration sur les droits
des femmes l'égalité etc mais on ne sait
toujours pas vraiment quel est son poste
au ministère de l'intérieur et emmanuel
macron qui bottent en touche et qui
allonge des budgets des chiffres alors
le budget de la sécurité afin de la
police c'est quand même
29,5 milliards d'euros pour ministère de
l'intérieur c'est le cinquième plus gros
budget de l'état avant l'enseignement
supérieur la santé la culture ou la
justice et malgré tout ça ne suffit pas
parce qu'il dedans il ya bien sûr la
police la gendarmerie
toutes les mesures pour l'immigration
les politiques intérieures la sécurité
civile et on voit bien que là encore
c'est un manque de moyens flagrant et
qui ne va pas être résolue évidemment en
deux mois d'élections présidentielles
donc effet d'annonce effet politiciens
et c'est bien là que
le bât blesse parce que il ne défendra
jamais son bilan non effet d'annonce
mais on voit que ça fonctionne quand
même dans l'animation la compagnie
puisque valérie pécresse a dû lui
rétorqué immédiatement et elle a fait
une déclaration à argenteuil notamment
qu'on va regarder
les recrutements très récent de deux
policiers parce que le candidat macron
veut faire oublier les défaillances du
président macro donc il ya eu des
recrutements très récent mais le rapport
de la cour des comptes est accablant il
dit que malgré ces renforts d'effectifs
il ya moins de policiers dont les noms
aujourd'hui dont je vous parle il y a
dix ans ce nicolas sarkozy alors valérie
pécresse a évidemment raison sur le
bilan des médailles et de le critiquer
ainsi le problème c'est où se
place-t-elle elle valérie pécresse elle
est quand même l'héritière de nicolas
sarkozy comme elle le dit et de françois
fillon aussi pourtant nicolas sarkozy
avait supprimé 10000 postes de forces de
l'ordre sous son quinquennat on s'est
pas privé de le lui reprocher nicolas
sarkozy avait promis de passer le
kärcher il n'a jamais passé et elle-même
croit habile devenir ressortir le
kärcher pour prouver qu'elles veulent
faire alors que son héros ne l'avait pas
fait ce qui est un petit peu absurde en
revanche elle se gargarise de chiffres
en disant qu'elle va créer vingt mille
places de prison qu'elle va armer la
police municipale enfin de rajouter des
amendes et qu'elle va en plus alors ça
c'est sur une autre question mais
proposer un plafond anti ghetto pas plus
de 30% logements sociaux c'est à dire
qu'elle va essayer elle toute seule
alors que la droite dont elle vient n'a
rien fait ou quasiment depuis 20 ans de
tout régler donc on voit qu'elle est
prise en étau entre sa volonté d'aller
sur le terrain de macron et la droite
dure qui est derrière elle et qui la
pousse à aller sur ses propres c'est
tout le problème en fait de valérie
pécresse et son positionnement est aussi
son bilan à la tête de l'exécutif
régional en région ile de france n'est
pas non plus faramineux l a pas fait des
tests ou d'aidés sorte de laboratoire
sur la sécurité donc elle arrive avec
d'un côté
une frange des républicains emmenée par
eric ciotti qui souhaiteraient beaucoup
plus radicale déjà certains ont quitté
la campagne c'est le cas de guillaume
pelletier qui rejoint eric zemmour et
puis de l'autre côté une frange de
centre-droit qui flirte avec l'électorat
macro ni ceux qui la voient comme étant
trop trop dur trop proche des idées de
marine le pen ou d'eric zemmour et donc
elle est coincée enfin c'est compliqué
pour valérie pécresse aujourd'hui de
trouver un positionnement politique
claire visible et qui va amener des
électeurs à voter en masse pour un
programme qu'elle n'a pas encore
totalement défini oui en fait elle a le
même problème de légitimité qui manuel
macron mais parce qu'elle n'a pas été
présent à la république elle était
ministre des gouvernements précédents de
droite et elle arrive aussi avec un nom
bilan de son de son parti et de son
courant d'idées sur ces questions de
sécurité voir quelle est la boule
reprocher même lac rond dire qu'il avait
rien fait sachant qu'en plus gérald
darmanin bruno le maire vienne de son
propre parti elle même est l'héritière
quoi qu'elle veuille deux parties qui
ont refusé de traiter ces questions pour
ne pas être associé au front national ou
rassemblement national cette époque là
et qui ont mis la tête dans le sable tel
l'autruche donc elle n'a pas cette
légitimité non plus quoi qu'elle essaye
de faire mais je crois qu'elle l'aurait
peut-être s'il n'y avait pas eu une
candidature comme celle d'eric zemmour
qui va compliquer la tâche peut-être de
valérie pécresse parce que justement
elles auraient pu faire cette alliance
avec un eric ciotti corps est davantage
de poids dans la campagne en disant
finalement toutes ces idées là je les
reprends et si vous n'êtes pas contents
et bien tant pis mais la droite
revient avec ces idées là là on sent
très bien qu elle est gênée elle
aimerait être emmanuel macron d'une
certaine façon pouvoir rassembler au
centre et en même temps montré qu'elle
est plus dure qu'elle a davantage de
vision sur l'autorité le régalien la
sécurité sans pour autant pouvoir
avancer un bilan où des équipes qui vont
sortir et se démarquer puisqu'ils
viennent tous du même parti les
républicains qui a donné des cadres au
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron donc c
c'est en fait un jeu à somme nulle on al
impression qu effectivement pour
beaucoup d'électeurs de droite voté pour
valérie pécresse se serait voté pour une
sorte de nouvelle emmanuel macron avec
quelques quelques ajustements
cosmétiques c'est sûr parce qu'en fait
je pense qu'il ya chez les deux des
sorte de pudeur de gazelle c'est à dire
qu'il nomme l'insecte une insécurité ils
disent les chiffres ils disent comment
ça se passe mais ils ne disent pas non
plus d'où ça vient contrairement à ce
que disent leurs concurrents plus à
droite que sont eric zemmour ou marine
le pen bref ya assez peu de liens avec
les endroits d'où ça sort et quelle
population pourquoi gérald darmanin vous
dis oui s'il ya des trafics de drogue
c'est parce qu'il ya des consommateurs
bourgeois ce qui est vrai en partie mais
il n'explique pas non plus quels types
de populations procure cette insécurité
aux français parce que valls à dinéault
qu'une partie de la population et donc
je pense que là dessus il se resteront
non crédible à côté de leurs concurrents
s'ils veulent pas nommé le saper les
français ressentent
[Musique]
direction le monde d'après alexis poulin
et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous jacques selon vous
quelles infos mérite cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
alors l'info qui va marquer cette
semaine c'est fabien roussel et russel
donc secrétaire du parti communiste
français et le candidat à la
présidentielle qui se distingue parmi
tous les autres candidats de gauche
aujourd'hui depuis yannick jadot jusqu'à
jean luc mélenchon en passant par anne
hidalgo en rappelant qu'être français
c'est aussi aimer manger du saucisson
boire du vin que la gastronomie
française fait partie de notre identité
et qui a aucune honte à en avoir alors
il me rappelle dans ce sens là il
applique simplement ce que disait son
maître ancien lénine qui disait tout
cuisinière de recevoir gouverné l'état
finalement c'est là dessus qu'ils va et
il a tout à fait raison de le faire je
pense de manière à la fois logique et
légitime d'après moi mais aussi même de
manière électoraliste si on peut dire
parce que il est cerné par la gauche oak
la gauche des colonialistes la gauche
qui n'aime pas ce que représente la
france et il est le seul candidat de
gauche à assumer de dire moi j'ai des
jets des électeurs qui se souvient des
classes populaires qui aime manger du
saucisson boire du vin qui aime être
franc c'est tout simplement de leur
région ou de houe de la france en
général et je vais parler à ces gens là
qui on en marre d'être méprisés par une
bouche qui leur expliquent toute la
journée quand il faudrait se comporter
et qu'il faudrait être vega de rouler à
30 km heure avec une voiture électrique
alors qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens oui
non mais clairement la stratégie roussel
ces deux d'essayer de partir à la
reconquête de l'électorat populaire du
côté gauche pour le coup avec des thèmes
qui étaient ceux du parti communiste
dans les années 60 70 enfin tout ça a
changé très récemment à partir du moment
où le parti communiste devenait déjà un
parti de progrès le progressiste de
robert hue et cetera d'eau qui revient
aux fondamentaux ça fait mal évidemment
puisque la gauche aujourd'hui est
empêtré dans les 50 nuance de oki sme et
de gauchisme d'ailleurs mangé du
saucisson boire du vin c'est vu comme
étant un signe du patriarcat blanc
oppressif pour certains donc c'est
compliqué évidemment de sortir une
bouteille de pinard et du sauciflard
donc pour fabien roussel c'est un choix
politique qui peut évidemment l'aider à
se positionner au sein de l'électorat
populaire après à gauche c'est une autre
histoire mais après je pense qu'il reste
un vrai marxiste léniniste qui se dit
que le wookie semer encore une maladie
infantile du socialisme aujourd'hui et
que c'est pas ça que veulent ces
électeurs qui veulent d'abord de la
justice sociale qui en ont assez des
inégalités des inégalités réelles
socio-économique et pas des inégalités
fantasmé par des par des professeurs
d'université
tu es horizon des fadaises auquel ils
veulent croire donc il a raison d'aller
se dresser à cet électorat là qui a été
préempté en partie par marine le pen est
un peu par jean-luc lâchement à la
dernière élection mais on ne va plus sur
ce terrain là donc je pense que d'aller
s'adresser à cette france périphérique
populaire wallon avait rapporté des
points à fabien roussel oui je pense
qu'aussi c'est des débats peut-être plus
important parce qu'on a une autre gauche
à la gauche de gouvernement comme elle
s'appelle elle même le parti socialiste
qui est en train de perdre tous les
électeurs inde dans un internement
incroyable avec la primaire populaire ça
y est il semblerait qu arnaud montebourg
la remonte à da et bien soit en train de
faire là des branches ada il arrête sa
campagne après la dégringolade à il se
dit que c'est pas possible de continuer
dans ces conditions là est peut-être
qu'il pourrait rejoindre une potentielle
candidature de christiane taubira qui
est arrivé au dernier moment parce que à
gauche enfin au parti socialiste on va
dire ce qu'il a manqué finalement c'est
l'épisode primaires du parti socialiste
tout simplement tous ces gens là avaient
leur place dans une primaire du parti
socialiste même s'il n'était pas encarté
ce qui s'est passé chez les républicains
le montrait c'était possible de revenir
et de se soumettre au suffrage des dd
des militants ils n'ont pas vous oublier
qu'ils ont peut-être le traumatisme de
dernières primaires du parti socialiste
d'accoucher de benoît hamon et c'est
bien sûr s'en est remis à l'année mais
évidemment mais mais regardez même sens
primaire ils sont tous à moins de 5%
donc quel est le résultat finalement
c'est encore pire que d'avoir fait une
primaire en plus manuel valls aurait pu
revenir peut-être vous aurez écoutez moi
après tout vous êtes ma famille
politique je reviens là on voit quelque
chose de terrible avec à yannick jadot
qui refuse de faire cette primaire lui
parle même d'une logique sectaire
dangereuse à la temple solaire en disant
on va tous mourir dans cette salle à
moins de 2 5% évidemment jean luc
mélenchon qui n'a que faire de cette
primaire populaire en disant moi de
toute façon je suis bien plus loin dans
les sondages et j'ai un programme et je
trace mon sillon et puis christiane
taubira qui n'a pas de programme qui
arrivent et qui va récupérer finalement
leur voiture iballa pas de candidature
en vue d'un lancement on assiste quand
même à quelque chose d'assez fait six
ans et c'est un candidat déclaré à la
présidentielle arnaud montebourg qui se
retire au profit d'une personne qui
n'est pas candidate à la présidentielle
pour l'instant que je pense que c'est
assez neuf dans la démocratie mavs à une
cacophonie pire encore puisque c'est
anne hidalgo qui refusait de faire la
primaire finalement olivier faure
secrétaire du parti socialiste lui dit
si si ce serait bien que tu la face
quand même anne et donc au final on se
retrouve avec une candidate de plus
christiane taubira peut être un candidat
de moins arnaud montebourg mais au final
je ne pense pas que ça va aider en quoi
que ce soit un candidat de gauche de
cette cause socialiste a passé le
premier tour non puis elle va faire
encore une primaire tout seul cento dira
c'est à dire que là le être choisis par
un panel de militants
tout seul parmi d'autres et on sera
peut-être légitime dans ce sens là mais
je crois pas en tout cas on le verra la
semaine prochaine après sa déclaration à
bientôt j'ai créé bientôt ici c'est la
fin du duel des éditos vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre site rt france point tv et en
podcast sur toutes les plateformes vous
pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]